[Musique]
c'est gros boutons on a ici une entrée
auxiliaire vous choisissez si vous avez
votre sélecteur avec le bluetooth
l'auxiliaire le RCA ou alors carrément
le HDMI et oui parce que vous avez une
entrée HDMI et RC-2 ça c'est un truc qui
est marrant parce qu'on peut l'utiliser
comme enceinte de votre téléviseur vous
prenez une sortie HDMI depuis votre télé
par exemple celle-là derrière et vous
l'emmener directement là comme ça vous
profitez d'un son de légende en sortie
de télé alors ça ça va être vachement
pratique notamment si vous voulez venir
regarder des concerts depuis votre télé
et en plus de ça ils ont fait un truc
qui est assez malin au niveau de
l'application c'est le mode nuit pour ne
pas venir vous embrouiller avec vos
voisins l'application c'est celle-là et
dans l'application vous avez le mode
nuit et si vous voulez activer le mode
nuit vous l'écrive le mode nuit réduit
les sons les plus fort tout en
garantissant que les sons les plus
faibles reste audible activez ce mode
lorsque vous êtes connecté à votre
téléviseur via HDMI si on parle
justement tout de suite et éviter
d'entrer en conflit avec vos voisins
donc lorsque vous activez ce petit mode
nuit justement ça va venir diminuer les
sons piège HDMI et uniquement via la
HDMI on va retrouver ensuite trois
potards le volume fatalement et on le
voit ici en plus on a une indication
avec des LEDs vous voyez on est le
niveau qui monte et qui baisse sur les
basses sur les tribal les aigus les
aigus et là vous avez un petit switch
vous voyez j'appuie play pause morceau
suivant morceau précédent et ici un
petit commutateur pour le On Off ça
c'est très pratique ça rappelle vraiment
les amplis d'époque je trouve ça
vraiment très très beau et moi le truc
que j'aime en particulier avec ce style
Marshall que ce soit sur celle-là ou sur
d'autres et bien c'est qu'on retrouve
vraiment le design des amplis qu'on
avait dans les années 60 70 c'est
toujours le même logo c'est toujours la
même façon de faire c'est hyper efficace
c'est super beau et si vous voulez à
l'intérieur rock n' roll là franchement
vous êtes quoi faire et quand je vous
disais que j'aimais les produits de
Marchal je montais pas ça c'est une Stan
more 2 que je dois avoir depuis ou
peut-être deux trois ans à la maison on
retrouve bien ce design iconique le même
système de bouton qui font le succès
c'est enceinte Marshall et elle est
disponible en deux couleurs vous l'avez
soit en noir comme ça c'est la couleur
que je peux faire sauci étant dit entre
vous et moi mais elle est également
disponible en couleur crème bon et puis
tout à l'heure je vous parle de
l'enceinte on va peut-être s'écouter un
peu pour voir ce que ça raconte je me
mets un peu de musique je suis sur un
niveau les basses à 5 les aigus à 5 et
on se met le son comme il est alors
l'écoute un peu là vous allez voir
on peut venir monter les bastions très
honnêtement comme il est là ça suffit
largement
[Musique]
pareil pour les aigus
comme ça regardez
je vais pas le mettre trop fort j'aime
faire saigner l'oreille le truc que
j'aime bien ici déjà c'est que on le
sent tout de suite dès que j'ai allumé
les graves ouf ça ronronne mais ça
ronronne très très fort après libre à
vous de les baisser si vous en voulez
pas trop je me suis différent un morceau
de rock mais bon fatalement je peux pas
venir les mettre ici parce que j'ai pas
les droits je me suis mis du Métallica
j'ai mis différents trucs et je puis
vous assurer qu'il y a de la couille et
que ça envoie du pâté et après on en
sort qui est très précis au niveau des
aigus des médiums aigus on entend tous
c'est très clair le son est bien
maîtrisé et les médiums tout sont très
jolis ça c'est une des particularités de
Marshall ils ont toujours eu de très
beaux médiums que ce soit sur les amplis
ou sur les enceintes comme ça après il
faut savoir que vous avez un orbite 90
watts de classe D au niveau du subwoofer
vous avez deux amplis de 15 watts de
classe D également pour les médium et
deux amplis de 15 watts de classe D pour
les aigus pour les Twitter et là vous
pouvez écouter vous balader autour de ça
ça marche vachement bien et puis surtout
c'est très réactif lorsque je vais venir
monter le son directement vous voyez
directement j'enlève les basses je
préfère le DJ mais presque vous voyez là
je monte les grammes là je monte les
aigus c'est extrêmement réactif
directement pareil hop là j'arrête j'en
mets morceau suivant
morceau précédent
vous voyez c'est cool on a vraiment un
super son avec donc si vous voulez que
ça dépote à la maison vous pouvez y
aller et bien que vous ayez une seule
enceinte vous avez un son stéréo avec
des aigus qui sont projetés vers
l'extérieur pour un côté plus immersif
on a donc ici un nouveau système à trois
voies les Twitter les aigus les médiums
les graves les basses autre truc qui est
cool c'est que vous avez la mise à jour
qui se fait overdière qui se fait
directement automatiquement via votre
application l'application ici elle est
super basique vous allez retrouver un
égaliseur c'est exactement la même chose
que vous allez avoir avec vos boutons
donc rien de bien neuf ici les basses et
les aigus une compensation de placement
ça c'est pas mal pour savoir si votre
enceinte est placé près d'un rebord oui
non ici oui c'est le cas et est-ce
qu'elle est placée près d'un mur ici
aussi c'est le cas non au sol oui un mur
oui dans le coin comme ça ça vient
maximiser l'expérience audio vous avez
fameux mode nuit que je vous montre tout
à l'heure à propos ignorer l'appareil et
après pour venir vous balader ici avec
de l'aide une LED d'information
d'analyse et qui sont générale etc etc
bon ici l'application c'est extrêmement
basique elle va surtout être là pour
venir faire les mises à jour et activer
ça me bonne nuit si vous en avez besoin
une application qui est disponible sur
iOS mais également sur Android tout en
sachant qu'ici on vient jamais été en
Bluetooth 5.2 cette Marshall wobble 3 je
l'aime bien je trouve intéressant le son
est bon il y a une bonne qualité
l'application est plutôt cool même si on
en fera pas grand chose globalement mais
j'aime bien et une fois de plus on est
dans l'idée de ce sont les gens de
Marshall et moi vous savez j'ai un côté
affect avec Marshall et si vous le savez
pas vous le savez maintenant parce que
je ne vous le dire parce que c'est mon
premier ampli enfin mon deuxième rempli
de guitare quand j'avais 14 ans j'ai
toujours connu la marque je l'ai suivi
j'ai regardé beaucoup de concerts de
rock où vous aviez des grands murs
Marchal bref j'aime cette marque et je
suis heureux de pouvoir l'avoir à la
maison et je vous le dis j'ai notamment
une autre enceinte là-bas Marshall à la
maison et plein de petits produits que
ce soit ici ou à Paris donc ça c'est
cool je suis convaincu par la marque
maintenant il y a un truc que j'aime un
peu moins bien pour cette version de 3
par rapport à la version 2 c'est que
déjà ici vous n'avez pas de connexion
Wi-Fi donc vous pouvez pas me dire
connecter votre enceinte dans votre
maison et puis le deuxième truc c'est
que vous n'avez pas de micro donc pas de
micro pas d'assistant vocal sur l'autre
produit que j'utilise aujourd'hui à la
maison Marshall et bien j'ai qu'à dire
OK et je peux piloter ma maison
connectée ici je ne peux pas c'est une
bonne enceinte c'est une très bonne
enceinte mais si je veux écouter de la
musique je peux pas avoir une commande
vocale et lui dire tiens mets-moi telle
musique mais moi si mais moi ça non il
faut reviennent avec mon smartphone je
me connecte en Bluetooth et là je peux
le mettre alors je peux l'utiliser aussi
en RCH je peux utiliser en HDMI ce qui
ça y est intéressant parce que ça
n'existait pas avant je peux l'utiliser
aussi avec l'entrée auxiliaire donc ça
c'est cool il y a pas mal de
possibilités mais il n'y a pas ici de
Wi-Fi donc il y a ce truc là qui manque
un petit peu pour autant est-ce que cet
enceinte est cool oui donc si vous
voulez vous faire plaisir à 569 €, vous
avez la wubber 3 Marshall je vous mets
le lien juste en bas dans la description
si vous avez des questions suggestions
interrogation allez-y en bas dans les
commentaires quant à nous on se retrouve
très vite pour continuer bien évidemment
à parler tech à parler d'audios à parler
d'objets connectés pour la maison on
pourra d'ailleurs ça c'est chouette je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt Ciao
[Applaudissements]